لقيت زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى
السعوديه ولقائه ولي العهد السعودي لقيت
صدى واسعا في الاعلام الامريكي حيث دعا
كاتب في الواشنطن تايمز الامريكيه كيفن
الى دعوه الامير محمد بن سلمان الى القاء
كلمه في الكونجرس لتكون فرصه للشعب
الامريكي الى الاستماع الى رؤيته حول
المنطقه واستشهد ايضا كاتب اخر في نيويورك
تايمز براي احد الباحثين في معهد دول
الخليج العربيه في واشنطن بين الرياض او
بان الرياض واشنطن تحاولاني اداره التحول
في العلاقه الى واقع متعدد الاقطاب جديد
لقد زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الاخيره الى السعوديه اهتماما بالغا من
اعراب الامريكي والدولي والتي اعتبرها
خطوه امريكيه جديده لاعاده بناء الثقه في
العلاقات بين الرياض واشنطن الكاتب
الايراني الامريكي والبروفيسور في جامعه
جورج تاون روب سبحاني طالبه في مقال له
على واشنطن تايمز البيت الابيض بالبحث عن
شركاء اقوياء لمواجهه التحديات العالميه
الدائمه الكاتب سبحاني وفي مقال لها قال
بان هناك خمسه عوامل تلخص دوافع الامير
محمد بن سلمان وهي حبه واعتزازه
المتبادلين للسعوديه وشعبها اضافه الى
رغبته في تلك لبلاده ولشعبه وثالثا تحويل
المملكه وشعبها الى قوه تغيير ايجابيه
عالميه الكاتب اضاف بالتزام ولي العهد
السعودي الثابت بتمكين النساء السعوديات
اضافه الى حبه الابتكار
التكنولوجيا للصالح العام الكاتب الكاتب
اضافه مشاهدينا بان على رئيس مجلس النواب
كيبل دعوه ولي العهد لالقاء خطاب في جلسه
مشتركه للكونغرس واعتبارها فرصه للاطلاع
الشعب الامريكي على رؤيته الكاتب اضاف في
مقاله بان ولي العهد السعودي محفز بدوافر
ايجابيه لخلق نهضه سعوديه جديده لذلك لا
يمكن روايه المتحده ان تجد شريكا افضل منه
لمواجهه التحديات العالميه
لها نشرته او في مقال نشرته ايضا حول
زياره بلنكن رايا حول حسين ابش كبير
باحثين مقيم في معهد دول الخليج العربيه
في واشنطن بان الرياض وهو شنطن تحاولان
اداره التحول في العلاقه الى واقع متعدد
الاقطاب جديد